[Music]
for my entire life I viewed self-love I
think as self-indulgent in the sense
that I felt it would be narcissistic and
selfish and unproductive to feel or
embrace or cultivate self-love in any
way and then fact the way to drive
myself was to constantly pick apart
everything I was or did in a very brutal
fashion in terms of internal monologue
and I think that that is part of what
drove me so close to the edge in college
is that incessant abusive inner voice
and I got a lot done you know I did a
lot of things and at the end of the day
who the cares really right like in
200 years we're all dust no one's gonna
remember us it doesn't matter right so
great I got a better grade on my junior
term paper who the cares right at
the end of the day that voice almost
drove me to extinguish myself so what
I've also found is that looking back at
the last 10 years like how you treat
yourself affects it it in some way
influences how you treat other people so
if you are violent and angry towards
yourself there will be an element of
violence and anger towards other people
whether it comes out really obviously or
it comes out in the form of like
resentment and complaining and passive
aggressiveness it's going to manifest so
spending time with jack Kornfield
has had a huge impact on me and this was
a few years ago when I first met Jack
he's a very famous meditation teacher
wonderful human being walks the walk
there are a lot of posers in the
mindfulness meditation world a lot of
people who
really are of the do what I say not what
I do school if you look under the hood
jack is so adept and as such an
incredible toolkit also as a clinical
psychologist for helping veterans that
adolescents were self harming and
cutting he's very skilled and we had a
lead a conversation at one point and he
said something that stuck with me and
I'm gonna paraphrase it because the
exact words are important but the gist
is and that is if your compassion
doesn't extend to yourself it's
incomplete and that seems so obvious
right but I do think that a lot of
people who pride themselves on being
achievers spend the vast majority of
their time whipping themselves and what
do you think I mean I think everyone has
that internal dialogue and some days it
can be more intense than others in terms
of being critical or for me it's it's
not so much critical myself as it is
just ruminating on certain thoughts and
like over and over again I I've had a
lot of that how did you break out of
that like what was it is something that
you still struggle with today like if
someone's listening to this they're like
oh my god that describes me to the tee
like I have all these I'm constantly so
harsh at myself what are the steps that
someone would take well some are easier
to recommend than others I've done a lot
of really wild stuff and some very very
aggressive stuff and it's not to say
that all tools will work for all people
but I do think that there are certain
books that have had a large impact on me
that have helped other people and in
fact now that I think about it I believe
that one of them radical acceptance by
Tara brach was recommended to me by
Daria which surprised the hell out of me
because Daria is very sharp
scientifically minded very skeptical and
at least back in the day my experience
with Daria was that anything remotely
woowoo or hand-wavy she was just like
talk to the hand not interested right so
when she recommended this book very
generic title and the subtitle I can't
remember at the moment but radical
acceptance Bottari Brock and I thought
oh my god like has Daria had a had a
frontal lobotomy like what happened I
don't know how this book he has it would
make it through her filter and it was
incredibly helpful so radical acceptance
self-acceptance making peace with parts
of us aspects of ourselves emotions we
have grown to believe our negative or
unwanted you know reconciling re
integrating yourself in a way is is a
worthy goal and I think I've largely
succeeded I still have my moments where
I beat myself up but it is less than 5%
of what it was five or six years ago
you